hi welcome to Julian and Jenna's [ __ ]
podcast cake big big big dick dang
welcome everyone back to Jenna Jillian
podcast it's a nostalgic day this is our
hundredth episode I'm for the record
very hungover right now so yeah so just
like with Jay Walker this is all Jays
fault yes but your but it's appropriate
because the first episode of this
podcast we had drinks yeah and that was
the premise on why we were gonna do
we're gonna sit around drinking [ __ ]
[ __ ] and here we [ __ ] are almost two
years later it's wild it's wild I'm like
it's it's it really snuck up on me 100
episodes yeah really quickly guys this
episode of the Jenna joined podcast is
brought to you by me undies get yourself
some of the hottest most comfortable
twice as soft as cotton underwear in the
game with coolest designs are going to
meet undies coms last gen Julian by far
like one of my favorite sponsors I've
ever had gift us things so we could you
know show you guys because it's I'm
wearing them right now analyze them all
I'm wearing them right now I love me a
nice they are so good please do yourself
a favor get yourself a pair ago and me
undies calm / Jenna Julian 20% off your
first order of me and he's also brought
to you by nature box nature box all the
delicious amazing snacks that are not
shitty for you and they taste amazing
and they have all sorts of different
styles of snacks sweet savory whatever
you want to live it right to your door
go to naturebox.com/tyler negate your
first two bags of snacks for free I got
something for naturebox a little later
but thank you to our sponsors thank you
to all of our sponsors who have ever
decided to sponsor this podcast and
thank you
to you guys for accepting our sponsors
and thank you guys for being so [ __ ]
amazing and being here at 100 episodes
it is so cool how's that how's that
going over that feels good looks like a
whoopee it literally is yeah there's one
haunted - it helps with my hangover it
helps yeah I'll see feel better all
right I'm going to wear it oh my arms
all right so guys what we did this week
was something different because its
100th episode we was trying to think of
a way to make it like special and
celebratory yeah and we settled on going
back and finding our favorite moments
from all some of them not all that
podcast but we found a lot of them yeah
um we did we a lot of time scrubbing
through old episodes to find parts we
liked and we brought them you know into
this video so basically what's going to
happen is we're going to give you you
know the first half of the podcast of us
right now talking to you and then the
second rest of it is going to be a
compiled video of our favorite podcast
moments or some of those pretty awesome
this moment school it was pretty awesome
yeah what what would you say is like
your some of your favorite podcasts that
we've done I still think that some of my
favorites are you sucking at celebrity
trivia I mean looking back on those
videos it's so funny like anything and
honestly I don't think I'm any better
now than I ever was
oh we can keep going so trivias I'm
going we are we also know we that we
promise you another conspiracy podcast a
long time ago we never delivered so we
will be coming back with that'll be
everyone wants shame we hear you we know
you and I know you want change so maybe
we can get chained here for part 4 is it
part 4 yeah might be yeah we're done 3
also I realize your mom is on three
podcasts wild lit the Debbie machine was
on three pumpkins so I don't know I mean
I kind of just I wanted to say thank you
to you guys for for being the dink fan
for for
joining our podcast family listening to
us talk every single week looking
forward to us talking you know tweeting
us that you know I've said this a lot
Jenna said this lot when someone comes
up to us in public and says they watch
the podcast it's it hits you differently
than when they just say they watch your
videos because we truly have something
cool where you guys you know podcasts
are interesting because you want to hear
us talk whatever it's about you want to
just kind of listen in on our
conversation and the fact that you guys
do that every week makes this so cool it
makes this in my mind one of the
greatest things I've ever participated
in in my entire life mm-hm and here we
are two years later and I'm just as in
love with the podcast as I ever thought
I could be you know I know it's wild
that we started doing this just because
you know we're live streaming a lot and
people are like hey I missed it because
you did it at 3 in the morning yeah
would you guys consider making a podcast
and we have the conversation and we
decided it made sense and I honestly
expected the podcast to like never
become anything except for like a small
group of people and I was hanging out
but it's been really cool to watch it
grow into an actual dank fam like we you
guys are the same people that go over
and watch the twitch stream and like
you're here with us like all the time
it's it's a different dynamic than you
know a lot of the other things and do a
lot more it's really cool there's very
intimate and I don't know it's just list
algae to think about the the podcast
journey it is you know yeah it is we've
had so much fun like we do things that
we don't usually do yeah like all I've
liked for years on my main channel you
know have plenty of ideas of things that
I'd like to do but they just don't make
sense yeah and I've been able to do a
lot of them on the podcast because they
make more sense for a podcast yeah
that's you know whether it be like a
topic that I want to talk about or a
game or something just silly stupid or
find a way to have my friends come over
and do something with me yeah or the
thought cast is always the perfect
medium that and and and the fact that
we've had
guests come on to the podcast that I
never thought jazz and talks in those
caliber people and you know you are so
nervous for that we clean the house like
so well we nervous clean yeah we nervous
cleaned everything um and going into
this podcast when you when you say we
sat down and talked about it basically
what you what Jenna means is we sat down
and we were like okay are we really
going to do this thing like it was just
like a straight-up real conversation
this is this is no joke we don't want to
do this half-assed will you be there
yeah every single week because when I
commit to things I'm not like half-ass
like no I'm not going to start a [ __ ]
you know whatever and then upload a
couple times and then forget about it
if I do something I'm committing to it
which is something I love about you
because I feel very similar and I don't
want to leave things I don't want to
leave things anyway we had this
conversation and it really felt like the
coolest opportunity to me like I could
have conversations with you but more so
like I thought I would get to like talk
and maybe interview and maybe do
something that I really did feel
passionate about at the time and still
do like I've loved interviewing and
talking to people you know in a public
setting or on like in front of an
audience or even if it was just five
people we're very good at it it's a
skill a skill which I don't have because
I'm just like loopy doopy the whole time
yeah we definitely have different skill
sets that's for sure and skill set
because if we have the same this podcast
would be boring and if we always agreed
to this hot gas would be boring that's
another thing that's another thing um
and every single conversation we've had
on daddy fighting those comments are
amazing like getting a divorce but it
really is such a beautiful thing about
the podcast is like we don't ever feel
like we have to agree on something and
that's okay that we're going to just
talk about it or debate or give each
other our own arguments or thoughts and
you don't like I don't think you guys
realize that if there was never any
disagreement on this podcast it would
get stale and it would feel like you're
not listening to two people talk you'd
feel like you're listening to two people
perform and a lot of the times in videos
you kind of have to
it on like a positive or a high-energy
thing but for this it's like we really
strip everything down yeah and you're
getting us just talking I know I had to
get really comfortable with some of the
like the little breaks that we take when
we're not saying something yeah I used
to freak me out to no end when I was
looking like there yeah I was like this
is this isn't okay like there needs to
be something there like we needed to
[ __ ] like pick it up I keep talking
and I took me a while to realize like
that's what makes a podcast like fun and
relaxed is that it's not just like super
fake high energy in your face like
you're listening to two people just kick
it man
I like that yeah but it was an
adjustment and I it was a good thing for
me to learn I feel like because not
everything needs to be so internet e in
your face it's true it rounded it like
rounds you out ten weeks do you remember
a long time ago when you when you
listened to my college radio show for
the first time and you're like what's
with all these pauses you're like so
uncomfortable it makes me not it yeah
and like I seeing your videos and like
learning what you did I was like of
course that makes sense that you'd say
that like what are these pauses is it's
so different but the meshing of what we
do outside of the podcast and what we do
on the podcast has kind of turned into
something really cool um yeah I mean and
so we went through and it was cool going
through the old videos I was just
watching the transformation of so many
things like the camera my hair the
orientation of each mossad is sat or the
green-screen yeah just watching
everything like our setup change is like
low-key you stir it's pretty funny
because every week it'd be like
literally almost every week there's
something different change oh we went to
the wide lens a couple weeks and your
arm look to you John all the comments
are like Jenni your arms are jacked and
then we have problems with the color
grading and we look busted well and like
a lot of them there's just like general
audio or visual problems it's a problem
not for a lack of effort though yeah I
mean it's hard to learn and teach all of
this stuff to yourself yeah no it is
this that we did one of the funniest
ones was just getting a camera that
would record for more than 12 minutes
ever
and remember that trip to Vespa they
were like this is exactly what you need
he was such a liar he's like for the
next 50 episodes of your thing one of
you won't be in focus that was really
funny that's funny you described it on
like a later podcast when we got the new
camera
you were like oh it made it fun though
cuz you got to use your imagination what
the other person looked like that's so
funny oh it's really funny but I mean
I'm really happy with how it looks now
how it sounds now how it is now yeah I
like I like our setup I think it's we've
kind of settled in on something cool and
also I mean the freakin green screen you
know it's we've we've graduated to
something remotely semi miniscule
professional rad it's pretty cool the
green screen is rad and we can use it to
make the [ __ ] as things it is so fun
yeah our green screen was on drugs last
week so sorry about that guys
what was it doing last week her
brockless oh who got popped by the way
there was no universe any of us we're
living in that he's clean sorry that's
not um look I also like that when we put
our green screen in a fictional universe
in Arcadia Bay so you guys have if you
have ideas for the green screen
backgrounds in future episodes that was
so that was your suggest that was your
listeners or viewers I think it came
about on Twitch that was a dope
suggestions really cool those were good
really good I have to say that one of my
favorite podcasts and one of the most
hated podcasts we've done is when I was
Sarah Palin the entire time and you were
Billy Ray Cyrus the entire time I don't
stupidest [ __ ] podcast ever and we
were just sitting there trying not to
laugh but somebody requested it and we
were both just like [ __ ] it let's do it
of course this is this is something we
do it's funny and like this is our
podcast it's so funny though that that
used to be a pod I used to be a podcast
yeah podcast yeah that's so funny
it's so funny man that was one of the
hardest things I've ever had to do
though just sit there not laugh I
basically the whole thing when I was
putting it in this video and they were
like like maybe two moments where you
break I don't like seven or eight when I
break cuz I can't even [ __ ] billy-ray
without making myself live it's so funny
Oh funny I mean most people if you're
not sitting at that table if you're not
me or Julianne it's not that funny but
it's how it was very funny yeah it was
fun though it was fun and um you know I
like the idea of like the podcast being
a living being and forever changing just
like everything else in this world like
you look back on 100 episodes you see
the arc you see the changes in us in the
podcast and the topics and everything
and I would only hope that for you know
the next hundred we see the same thing
you know like we're here now and if we
ever get to 200 which I plan on doing I
love to look at episode 100 and be like
wow you know what I mean I just think
it's like it's cool and it does it gives
you sort of a reference point of life
you know that sounds kind of weird and
deeper like you look at each episode and
that was a different day in your life
mm-hmm talking about stuff yeah with
underwear on the table it's in my lab I
mean I'm I'm honestly very proud of us
and the dig film because it started off
as like kind of a joke you know like
everything was a joke you can hear it in
how we introduce the first episode and
it's like [ __ ] no sponsors [ __ ] yeah
and we that did not foresee it becoming
like an actual time you always inner we
were going to give it everything we had
but we never saw it taking off or ever
getting some sort of regular thing yeah
sponsors
it's reject about sponsors for the first
20 episodes I when I was looking back I
think the episode was Shane might have
been one of our first was our first
first I was a person - yeah was it was
naturebox yeah naturebox yeah our first
sponsor and our budget episode sponsor
Ben Ryder died with us and I do want to
give a huge huge special shout out to
your mother Debbie for keeping this
podcast running Debbie machine and
allowing us to do this every week in
supporting us like what she does for
this podcast makes it so we have a green
screen makes it so we're here every
single week makes it so everything looks
good it's like she is the the killer
behind the scenes making it all happens
a huge thank you to Debbie we love you
yeah I love you Debbie
maybe we'll have you on for fourth or
fifth or sixth podcasts I mean that
honestly is so [ __ ] cool though
because I've made a video with my mom
but like every time I see my mom I can't
make a video with her that's kind of
overkill but the fact that when she
comes to visit and the three of us can
sit here and spend time together and
make something and have fun with her put
it on the internet and I can share my
mother with the world there who is
special and amazing and hysterical so
amazing and and not it look in the most
genuine way possible and that I get to
do that with my mom and spend that time
with her and how those things exist it's
like really cool and special it's pretty
damn cool you know like who else gets to
have their mom on their [ __ ] radio
show all the time not many people know
maybe we need to get my mom on here yeah
we do
your mom's ever gone right but she did
she'd have some dope [ __ ] oh you know we
should have on here francelina podcast I
mean I am dying in any capacity to work
with my brother because he's hysterical
but I've never asked him and I'm not
sure that I want to because he's got to
keep it keep it 100 professional off the
internet probably but most part just no
internet that you would love my brother
he's a way funnier more awesome version
of me he's incredible he's incredible
he's like sweet but he's also he's smart
he's like he's a scientist I than he has
a real soft side yeah kind of like this
underwear goofy ah that Segway was fired
my face Bergdorf
get yourself some me and these guys to
celebrate the hundredth episode of the
genitive ugh
and uh I want to find the exact episode
that you started doing fire segments
like it's a [ __ ] forest fire it's a
fire hazard
we uh we love me and you so much I'm
literally wearing them now these designs
come out I think every single month they
have new designs and they're the most
electric cool designs which is not even
the greatest part about the underwear
it's made of micro modal fabric Jen is
wearing it on top of her leggings right
now feel yeah and the micro moto
U is literally twice as soft as cotton
guys it's like you're not you can't you
can't comprehend what I'm feeling in my
hand when I do this like I'm feeling the
softest underwear ever feels like a
webby you know the web he is like what
kids call their blankets
Oh Kerry you're gonna baby blanket yeah
it feels like soft my brother you saw a
booby and it felt like like me and these
yeah it's just you ever have a blanket
or a stuffed animal when you're a kid
yeah I had bear bear bear bear yeah my
mommy I tell you about Barry yeah I
threw him out the window on the highway
because I want to see if he could fly I
had gray doggy yeah I know what a great
original name little Jen I gave her
little stuff like I love gray doggy shop
get yourself some mayonnaise by going to
me undies comm slash annejulien you get
20% off your first order and you will
absolutely not be disappointed
check them out our other sponsor this
week is nature box nature
hey rider diamond rider died our first
ever sponsor and now here with 100
episode seems very fitting thank you
thank you a nature box for all the
delicious snacks which we actually
already finished you don't have to show
you what since we finished all the
snacks and since I love nature box so
much and all their deliciousness that
they give us I wrote a poem oh I'm gonna
need it for you right now there are
moments in life that feel like nobody is
there to help you decipher or show that
they care it's in these same times that
a lending hand boosts your spirits and
shines like the Sun reflecting off the
beach
and hmm okay the strawberry lemon-aid
fruit stars are my Beach
they are my Sun my shining light and
life when I get lost in dark moments the
stars of my world show me love the sweet
and tangy chewy and smooth freshly
picked from the candy booth and
delivered to my mouth with a groove
gives me the love that my life so
desperately needs I love you naturebox
thank you for bringing those
strawberries oh my god I mean you have a
career
thank you yeah yeah yeah I can go to the
edge you should make it a song yeah
maybe I'll own naturebox ah please
continue to sponsor us so that I can
keep writing your poems and songs
because it's truly from the heart those
strawberry lemon-aid fruit stars I
really changed my life they're really
good
I have a question is when I only sat in
here and I said something to you real
quick and you go shut up and writing
something is that what you're writing he
literally looked at me and like Snap was
like shut up I'm writing something it
was like I was in the third to last line
and I was about to finish that beautiful
strong finish that meant so much to me
just like the the fruit starts oh yes I
snapped at you shut up writing so you're
writing about fruit stars guys goodnight
you voxcom class generally and get your
first two bags of snacks for free and
you won't be disappointed you'll be back
for more oh my god
all right guys so we really want to say
thank you for a hundred episodes yeah we
amazing it's amazing and it makes us so
happy happier than you guys could ever
imagine we hope that you enjoy this next
part where we go through and just put
together some of our favorite moments
from 100 episodes mmm and as always let
us know in the comments whatever's on
your mind or whatever your favorite
parts were or you know stuff that you
want us to
mitch or can reference it in the next
podcast you know just because this is
the hunch it doesn't mean we can't talk
about old podcast trail for sure I mean
it's just I'm I'm really overwhelmed
like I have a very nostalgic person to
think I get really like sappy when it
comes to stuff like this and I'm really
excited that we're doing this and then
we had just like a little moment of like
pause and reflection and celebration
because it's [ __ ] cool and like when
I look back on my videos like I made a
hundred video and a 200 video and a
300th video like I think it's important
to take moments of pause for milestones
and just be like this is [ __ ] rad
yeah and I just want to take a minute
and say thank you and like [ __ ] this is
cool yeah you know very cool
this is [ __ ] cool but I mean we went
through and picked out some of our
favorite parts so hope you guys yeah
hope you like it cuz it's it's goofy and
we're getting I'm like getting oh do you
want a hug let's podcast hug we ever
hugged on the podcast Oh
first time for everything I mean you
wrote a poem I didn't know you're gonna
cry I'm not gonna cry do not cry cry cry
cry cuts the blush that's a tall they
cried a peach please enjoy the next clip
of all of our favorite moments that we
found and we love you guys very much we
will see you next week for a much less
sappy very mad hundred and first podcast
yeah bye guys bye ding bim so anything
up things happening this is our special
guest
brett the debbie mushy the gabbie show
kids here Jason and Gaby wonderful and
talented Jasmine talks
Josh Alka went up Josh grande Joey wall
Matt Chris no burger and Cher
Syrus Shane Dawson Dominic d-trix in the
wall Hey
my younger brother Marlon really Keaton
and Matt from techsmartt survivor winner
john cochran jaywalker he has he allowed
me for this phone just guess what group
was Nick Lachey I know it you 18 degrees
I don't know you're so close only 98
degrees yeah I was one number off number
make much hotter you're getting warmer
but you're still frozen 18 degrees okay
um can you name any other members of
that group 98 absolutely not
not even close okay you want to hit yeah
one of them is related to Nick Lachey
Jarmusch a disease brother yeah Jake
Lachey no this is assistant nose boy
band
Adam Lachey Nick Lachey the third I
don't know I don't know Nick Lachey's
brother's name this is real brother
stake brother that's how your thing
thanks with a deep Donovan Lachey no
Drake Lachey no it's short for and dick
Lachey ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding think
ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding
ding-ding-ding
um I want to play you something that
made me laugh for like 15 minutes
yesterday scream laugh scream laugh and
cry you didn't even record it or
anything
I didn't nope it's probably the worst
remix I have ever heard
who's the captain I gotta find it
oh no Jimmy goes down Jenny goes down
these deep rabbit holes of Twitter like
videos on Twitter and like tweets and
just dies laughing yeah but now I don't
know where it is Kevin I found it it
just says terrible are you ready for
this I don't think they are who know
they could be my momma don't get that
close
I find it common I find it funny I don't
find it like hey you see the way that
they put the audio files together they
just put them like on top of each other
they didn't even remix it they did
nothing to it the beginning kills me
though that's pretty horrible it's
pretty freakin horrible is the best
thing I've ever heard
no I have heard Miley's music so I
called you a liar now no I said I try
not to listen to it because it doesn't
align with me personally okay so to
answer your question what why did that
happen or when did it happen when oh it
happened um when when that I was with
Miley and we were about to watch her on
the Disney Channel
cuz she was good on it she is a good
actor and oh your commercial came on and
she said daddy what's that and I said
don't look those too late she was dumb
now are you calling me dumb and after
Miley Cyrus just makes music about
popping pills and just doing everything
bad that the Bible explicitly tells you
you cannot do this and get into heaven
and you're calling me stupid oh no I
didn't call you I'm just saying that you
were the sole reason she became the way
that she is in every bad sense of her
character I understand
but okay my original question was what
were your thoughts as a father oh well I
was really really drunk but I mean it
was okay though cuz I woke up the next
day and I still had a roof
my head cuz my daughter paid for it and
then we went on tour so I forget what
you know who John Krasinski is obviously
is a huge fan of the office
yes massive fan of him and the office
who was he married to oh is it
um Pam no it's not pam pam it's not pam
pam it's it's not Pam then I don't know
I don't even think he's married probably
it's Emily Blunt ah she's in uh she's
like the dark hair she's falling she's
got like darker eyes
sounds like a lady square job mm-hmm was
she in yeah was she in that movie with
Matt I met a kid again I'm sorry again I
think I know what you're talking about I
don't know the name of that movie but I
think you're right really recently yeah
what a nice creature keeps like dying
and coming back oh yeah yeah oh my god
okay that's right
I know yeah her name is Emily Emily
Blunt Pam Halpert okay this is called J
and J troubles it's by chase Elliott um
on Wattpad rookie are you ready should I
get it you can but I want to start
reading you you ready a girl
my friend says Jenna ending her newest
video all right now what peach karmic
marbles she says talking to her dogs
three of them just look at her Jenna
gets up from her chair and heads to the
living room to watch a movie as soon as
she should sits down her phone rings
it's a random number so she doesn't
answer her phone keeps ringing and
ringing and ringing finally she answers
it what the hell do you want she shouts
Jenna it's me Julian he's at whispering
Jenna
it's me Jillian he says whispering
Jillian had left to go to the store to
get more kale
I'm in some trouble I was kidnapped and
I need your help
he says still whispering are you serious
how did that fleet never mind
what do you need me to do she replies I
need you to not call the police
and the phone call ends Genesis they're
frightened thinking this might be a
prank but she knows Julian sounded
serious
she runs upstairs and packs a week worth
of stuff and a decent amount of cash
she takes the dogs to her mom's house
and lies to her mom saying Julian her
going on vacay okay Jenna runs to the
car and takes off driving to Julian's
brother house Marlin is a hacker and
that's the best pilot is a hacker
inconel ya know nice free snacks right
to your door what are you guys waiting
for naturebox common angelina started
free trial today khan asaf yeah connor
franta eats us so you should write it's
true it should just be there only tag
hood we don't want that tight little
twink body so it's so tight and twink
what is twing twing kits like a little
it's like a little gay boy who's like
really like careless and tiny mmmm
so no okay gotta not us we would be I
think classified I had a gay guy on my
talk is he classified all of us cuz I'm
a cub of these Gators oh I saw that I'm
looking yeah it was a cub right Mike of
it okay URI yeah yeah you're a little
too muscular to be a cub I don't know
what a muscle is maybe like oh not a
bear cuz that's fat it's like dad what's
it what's a gay guy your gaydar cuz
that's me I can never tell it when
anyone's gay that's true you can't look
at a hairless cat huh okay oh good you
are here ELISA watching your vlogs I've
noticed you I know I don't have that
much no I know that hair on my chest is
just like how yeah really
well alright it's crazy [ __ ] off except
on my legs I have hair how's Jenna knows
yeah master nothing [ __ ] wax the [ __ ]
out of that I did I wear on your ass
yeah yeah
you'll see maybe later if you guys
watching naturebox we'll start with some
nature of ours maybe some dinner
Jena is that too much do you have nipple
hair I know earlier here is a thing that
I didn't know it is it's the thing
well that is this no you're kidding yeah
it's real yeah she don't know that
lately
hey don't think for my nipple on my
meeting bring my book to her hey cancel
you clean that up
oh yeah inappropriate love anyways guys
naturebox calm
made in Australia no we won't do that
our head Oh
oh my god get you damn it
oh this podcast I probably screamed good
hosting who's this Julian are you
[ __ ] leave a which I was not [ __ ]
with you yes clear honest this is not
Julia Roberts this is the other one
remember that is Julia Roberts not
Gerard's it's the one that you kept
calling the other one I don't know that
is Lisa listen this is like Julia
Roberts this is a different actress
entirely yeah you sure what's her first
name starts with an S Sandra Bullock
Sandra Bullock this is not really wrong
this is this is where all your problems
come from you just think people are
other people and you have no idea who
anybody is Jonah this is it's just a
startling picture that's all you ready
for this oh god I can't put on your
Hanson
this is
who's the host of wheel fortune uh drew
Carey no that's another show
why are you doing this it's just started
dammit I don't watch any of those bark
all right they've been on forever I
figured that they were safe questions I
know the answer I just like I've watched
it with you well sort you do you know
the format of Wheel of Fortune leap what
happens them
yeah they spin the wheel and then what
we have to guess the word of the fortune
before the word is that the moment they
spell out the word yeah yeah we played
that on our iPad just fell the fortune
yeah we do either okay who stars on we
hook wheel for tits Pat Sajak that's a
dad who stars on wheel of fortune with
him hmm
I'm wheel of fortune fortune is it a guy
or girl what true Carrie I don't know
you're talking about is coho feelings
already asking sort of it's well yeah
the voice no it's a woman Oh Dan Hawaii
I thought you I thought she was Jeopardy
didn't she didn't think it's a free Alex
Trebek miss reading these very serious
trivia but she's up there like turning
the answer oh I thought that's there is
a girl who does that right it's just
some girl though no yeah who never
guessed I was that Harry Potter yeah but
I know his name
give me the first letters Daniel
Radcliffe oh my god okay who's this I
think we did good yeah but that [ __ ]
violent drunk is gonna kill us all no we
have a marine he can handle him okay
he's got a gun he's just [ __ ] about
the gun do you know could I kill them
really quickly is the horse that farts
fire yeah that would have been a
disaster it would have been amazing
yeah enjoy having [ __ ] fiery dead
people because you're even cook our food
with this fire yeah all this food smells
so good and then this [ __ ] horse fire
farting and it suddenly isn't so damn
appetizing it's funny until you're
hungry and your food is fart right right
when you go to sleep he's like I love
you baby good night
oh you're lit on fire by a fart good
night you're dead
that was a great way to die Wow
that source of heat if you could get
over the smell the concert you could get
over this yeah [ __ ] right I'm not
getting over that smell Oh y'all out all
[ __ ] off myself I'm going up to the
radiation by none is anymore too dark
and clothes like bomb shelter and it
smells like horse farts lit on fire
any dump so literally drowned in his
[ __ ] in like a wood but he's such a good
friend
oh and you can write and can't argue
with that
[ __ ] you had she just like [ __ ] all over
the room it's as far as what okay again
think about this phone he would have no
tail because it would be gone so when it
got like lit on fire a long time ago
okay I'm so glad we don't have a fire
farting horse goodbye horse do Justin
and Jessica have any kids
nah yeah but they want dude the heavy
how many just how is it it's good I mean
I don't know personally but everything
seems to happy like when you answer one
of your so [ __ ] no boys but they love I
can't
they don't know what crying other than
wolf face yeah
that's all they know what anyway so she
doesn't wake up when they cry or bark I
do but I was up anyway I was up like two
hours something before Jenna this
morning and I was downstairs doing stuff
and the bedroom door upstairs was open
so I could hear Kermit crying which if
you can kind of imagine I'm in the
office listening the stuff on my
computer and I still hear is crying on
top of on top of everybody and like this
is like oh my god crying like he's
trying to wake you up with a crime
Mikey chose he chose crying as a method
to wake you Julien after years of that
wouldn't you become accustomed talking
yeah [ __ ] wish I could hell
well nothing
is normally out I don't know what it is
I always wake up when he cries but I was
up and he starts crying and it's so loud
that I can hear from downstairs I'm like
you know what I'm not going to deal with
this I walk upstairs and I pick him up
curl it no more crying
you can't cry mommy awake so I pick him
up take him downstairs peach follows me
because she's good about following me
and going where I go and I bring him
downstairs but I shut the bedroom door
so he can't run back up there so we're
hanging out downstairs we're walking in
the kitchen I put him down like to go
outside because peach is heading outside
and he does this thing we puts on the
brakes and he turns directions it goes
the other way like brute and he like
makes this noise like he's getting shot
at how to police and he Sprint's
upstairs like you saw that vlog of mine
when he Sprint's up the stairs that's
what he did he like superhuman speed
because he's scared of me I don't know
and so he Sprint's up the stairs he like
basically like jumps and like tries to
like shoulder charge the [ __ ] door
open because he knows I'm like behind
him and he's a fan of him the doors not
opening so I don't even go upstairs I
just let him do his [ __ ] weird little
nervous tic and he goes like clawing at
the door you know and then he stops and
then I'm like okay whatever he'll figure
it out you know he'll deal with the
situation as he needs to so I lay on the
couch I'm hanging out with peach doing a
couple things on my phone and 10-15
minutes passes and I'm like where's
Kermit like he's not in the bedroom the
door shut where did he go and I'm like
hermit and I look up on like the
mezzanine like a little balcony in our
living room thing and he just trots over
and he just like looks at me he just
like looks at snapchatted because he
just like looks at me and he's like and
like hermit did you just wait up there
are you just waiting one little baby
step at a time first I want to make us
not look completely busted why is there
a fly in the podcast room this place is
supposed to be quarantined hmm this is
going to be distracting he better
[ __ ] settle no isn't that bames
that's that's not babes babes as video
games is kept my that's my makeup and
there's a fly in the room and Julian was
being mock and I was like oh there's a
fly and he's like yeah that's my Pat his
name is James James the fly I mean this
isn't babes babes it names is way better
behaved
mmm okay got it GTFO you babes and purr
there oh my god this is gonna drive me
nuts stop looking at him ker stop
looking at beams it's not the babes
impostor
it's like it's like an Elvis Presley in
Vegas he's one of those beams I'm just
kill him by the end of the podcast kill
him that's your objective if you want a
podcast alone I'll hunt him down it'll
be like that episode of Breaking Bad the
whole episode is dedicated killing one
fly I mean you should probably get a
weapon ready that's all you can do ma
she came so close to you my god he's
like he's rubbing in my face for that
for those you guys listening on
Soundcloud 19 I'm sorry there's a fly in
our room and it's really [ __ ]
annoying yeah what if this whole podcast
is just us talking about where it is in
its current status then you'd be really
frustrated if you're listening and not
watching or would it be like a riveting
horror story because you don't know
what's happening that or if I could be
one of the other if you hear a loud slam
- it's probably me knocking always right
there oh all right you know what Jenna
you're talking about jobs and [ __ ] I'll
make her happy
Julianne's wheat like he's not gonna be
able to focus and you unlock your
headphones oh here we go man um yeah we
should talk about our old jobs but like
starting in order from earliest to most
recent yeah I like that and because I
used to have some funny stuff or some
weird stuff what was like oh my god
food oh he's really he's got a magazine
right now why did you fold that I was
keeping that tool in a there's coffee
all over okay you weren't keeping it yes
I was it was it's a magazine that my
keep it sent me from Sirius XM and
there's like a tiny little picture of me
in it so I kept it cuz I keep that kind
of thing it's nice it's exciting and
this [ __ ] using it to kill a
fly it's over here he's in front of the
lights he's over my head oh my god
Julian I swear oh okay no all right
career
oh okay this podcast has the rest
hey Julian you better get him I'm trying
he's so bad oh my god he just like
Michael Jordan gentleman across the
I didn't owe you much oh it's over man
is over my head it's over my head I need
a good angle of room mmm so what was
your first job okay so here here's
what's gonna happen I'm going to tell
you about some of my first jobs and
Julian is going to narrate his flight
activity in the background oh yeah good
work doing it why you bring him over
here going you put him away [ __ ]
is gone good nice all right you know all
right get the [ __ ] down we go into the
movie thought that she was gonna take an
hour flight do you want to go first yeah
go first yeah I have like a bunch of
superheroes so you want to you do one go
ah the first one that I want to exist is
the Hunger superhero where whenever
you're hungry he just comes gives you
snack think of all the global problems
that could be enjoying a hunger
superhero
so is he is he basically like as fast as
- from The Incredibles is that how he's
able to do it or is he just imagine like
a Santa for food okay doctor so
basically how does it work how does it
work you say I'm hungry and he shows up
or what is this day well just timeout
for one second because we don't have to
logically explain Superman or spider-man
and how they know where everything's
going on so I'm not going to explain
hunger man okay don't hold me to that
I'm not gonna logically explain to you
how he gets to every hungry person in
the world he just does fair enough fair
enough fair enough fair enough
all right um traffic man basically what
this guy does is he has instead of webs
shooting out of his hands he has roads
shooting out of his body so he can build
roads by flying somewhere and the road
is already built so basically if there's
ever an area that needs expanded roads
construction done basically anything to
alleviate traffic which literally is
everywhere
in our world today because so many
people are everywhere he would just fly
over and he would build a road right on
top of it like a second level or
somewhere off the side he could build
roads in seconds Kendrick man penny also
disassemble the roads oh yeah yeah yeah
big time he can fly through it is it and
then it would be like a big cloud and he
[ __ ] leaves and you're like wow I
think that's key though because you
can't just have roads all over this
traffic man because that is what he does
not allow in this world because he
creates a world with no traffic mmm and
it's beautiful
thank you thank you um uh trademark this
one's pretty easy okay guy tries
adderall whole world gets wrecked by him
limitless sorry I don't see that man you
don't need to right like when they
started putting commercials up for it
you're like okay so adderall documentary
[ __ ] cocaine be like we get it is
that Johnny Depp [ __ ] if it's limitless
paper in a paperless world what a
transition we are gonna play a dunder
mifflin trivia game the office truth
that was literally from the office and
it applied right now okay first of all
I'm wearing my glasses which is very
stressful for me I slept in my contacts
by accident so now I'm wearing my
glasses
Julianne literally just five seconds ago
super glued them together guys I don't
know what to do to get you in a / she
has these broke-ass glasses that always
like the lens just pops off you're not
it's almost like oh please that is not
why they are broke yes no it is not yes
it is no it is not I win because you
didn't respond the the lens pops out and
like it's like got a mind of its own it
comes out at the worst time yeah like
one time she was she was about a catch
peach and the lens fell out and she like
didn't know where she was in peach Fox's
our depth perception
I don't I'm not saying you you know your
your visions at fault here it's more of
you need new glasses I don't know what
to do she won't get new glass if I may
be like what do I do
how do I get your prescription I don't
know what does that mean you don't know
you need to know this why why do I need
to know I don't need to know you need to
know
it's a need-to-know basis and you need
to know
it's on a piece of paper it was in the
front hall but I lost it but my mom said
that I could just walk in there and be
like hi I need a new person alone sir
yeah then go do it listen I don't - she
black shell absolute function all right
so this guy's crossing the street and he
went up to some car and went to the
window it looked like he was taking his
band taking money or see homeless no oh
this guy's they got a Turner girl what
the hell is that
see ya what classic them so just look at
us and then they get a turn out there
like smug like we get to turn I don't
think anyone just did that yeah that was
made up
anyway it's 23:37 it's been 20 minutes
mm-hmm no like like like live all right
am I good I got one right there Mike
other my [ __ ] come on click do it again
other my [ __ ] other my [ __ ] stop
switching beers look what you did made
it all foamy yes it's gluten E all right
Julian sure of it when I got my conch
Pierce which is the piercing that's
through my entire cartilage on my right
ear and right hate that word conch the
shell no but like when you say I got my
de Koning okay okay
don't make a nasty grooming [ __ ] nasty
her name is you and the bag is like half
full of chips so funny let's look at the
bag half full not the glob okay but like
even okay if you buy a big sized one
it's not as bad no it's it's a hundred
small ones so little want a little like
a 99 cent bag of look you just want
something bigger there's never you never
know because they're all my chips yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] man why is that ah you
know I don't know they like to look at
the bag half full so I know you're
looking at half empty but they like to
look at it as half full
your face is twitching stop doing that
could be face mm-hmm
all right I got one ready yeah
Victoria's Secret let us measure you
even though you had breasts for over a
decade every time I go in there if you
start looking at a bra they're like oh
do you need to get measured and like
[ __ ] doesn't look like I need to get do
I look like I woke up with these titties
is all you say they just are on say like
some of them and they're just assumed
that you're like an idiot and then that
you don't know what your bra size Rises
how can I not know what my bra size is
to be fair they are experts no not
you're right they're not they're not at
all oh my god they make me frustrated
though too
I like their sterling I'm not gonna lie
those drawers it feels like you're in a
big closet you just open the drawer and
you take the underwear that you I mean
that sounds creepy I'm not in there
alone but no it's a cool layout like
you're like oh what sighs all right
let's go to the third drawer down yeah
it saves a lot of space - is it nice but
yeah that's [ __ ] so I'm just like
I've given into the oh do you need to
get measured thing a couple of times and
they should go you're nice I am I feel
bad yeah but they're probably bored at
work and just want to measure some
teddies anyways but like they came out
of all people like if I go to the mall
chances are I'm probably wearing like a
sports bra and they'll measure you and
be like oh you're like a 34 a and I'm
like [ __ ] don't you know I'm wearing
like a compression bra right now like
that's not the size of my boobs and this
is why I don't want to get measured
because you're wrong you should know
that's what happens when you wear a
sports bra and they don't care then
they're like here let me pull some bras
for you I'm like please don't cuz that
shit's not gonna fit on my titties mmm
Teddy's Teddy's this is a passionate
issue for you art that's not it does it
pisses me off hmm I'm sorry like
shouldn't I be the one to measure my own
boobs you know you should do with a
measuring tape you need a way I don't
have a swatch this is what we need to do
next time we go to Victoria Secret just
bring a measuring
even when they say can we measure you be
like only if I can measure you I'm not a
surprise right that's actually a good
idea we should do it mmm I like since
when are you certified as an employee of
Victoria Secret to touch my boobies with
your hands this feels like the grip is
ooh I didn't open the grub seal for you
this feels like the grubs ooh mmm I
don't like that at all Tori a secret the
grubs it is open that's a good slogan
how's it good slang hi good sorry
hopefully there will be more of these
and this has been fun and this is
usually what we do over the weekend
right happy we're recording this for the
internet system this is what we we are
[ __ ] do we get a drink and we just
stay here and talk yeah so a lot of talk
about glad that we did this I'm excited
to be back spectacular
we did it Jay and Jay podcast but it's
not Jay and Jay it's Julianne Jenna
no it's Jenna and Julianne your first
Jenna and Julianne your first well
alphabetically speaking I'm first your
first in the podcast all we actually
have Twitter Instagram YouTube all set
up we just haven't released it so all
right all right sounds good we are
hoping to do this every week but who the
[ __ ] knows who knows we will no
expectations no rules no expectations
those rules we're gonna try to be as
consistent as possible but at the same
time living by our anti rule rule cook
we love you guys all right love you
see you guys next time see you next week
bye bye
you